c'est une salle comble et attentive qui
a accueilli samedi dernier à
mantes-la-jolie la candidate de lutte
ouvrière nathalie arthaud s'était déjà
présenté en 2012
dans son discours ce week end elle a
rappelé l'importance du combat des
travailleurs une voie qu'elle estime
être la seule à porter pour 2017 contre
vous écouter la télévision ou la radio
les seuls candidats que l'on entend à
c'est la droite c'est le parti
socialiste ces macro tous ces gens là
ils sont unanimes unanimes pour dire que
les travailleurs ils ont trop de droits
que les travailleurs sont trop bien à
protéger l'industrie fait partie de
l'adn des yvelines second bassin
d'emploi après la défense l'actualité
récente a fourni au soutien de nathalie
arthaud des arguments pour sa campagne
dans un groupe hyper riches renault il
ya un plan de compétitivité ou les
patrons voudrait faire faire aux
travailleurs des heures supplémentaires
gratuites samedi etc
et pendant ce temps là il ya 6 millions
de chômeurs du côté des autres militants
rassemblés à mantes la jolie
l'enthousiasmé ne fléchit pas pour la
candidate qui n'a rassemblé que 0 points
56% des voix en 2012
dans la droite continuité d'arlette
laguiller dont elle fut la porte parole
nathalie arthaud incarne les idées de
son parti
ce n'est pas par les urnes que ça
changera les choses ce n'est pas
en élisant un candidat qui prendra place
au pouvoir que les choses changent on
s'est parlé lutte que les luttes
sociales qui ont fait bouger les choses
c'est à dire c'est quoi il faut pas
miser sur le cheval gagnant pour miser
sur celui qu'on veut et le nathalie
c'est pas un cheval c'est des idées
qu'elle véhicule et c'est pour ça qu'on
vote c'est pas pour une personne après
ce passage dans les yvelines nathalie
arthaud partira dès janvier pour une
série de meetings à travers toute la
france
objectif réveiller les travailleurs
comme elle se plaît à le dire